ما شاء الله يعني الشعب غلبيته 70% اقل من
عمره 30 ضعف النظر زي تساقط الشعر يعني
اكثر
يعني مع الوقت حيكون في طلب اكثر واكثر
المنتجات البصريه ما تشوف الليزك
والعمليات هذه تقلل الناس اللي ما تحل لك
المشكله يعني ممكن بعد خمسه عشر سنين
بتضطر انك تستخدم منتجات
والله يعني نتمنى يعني يكون في حل بس حتى
يعني ما له دخل لا تزال ممكن تلبس نظارات
شمسيه
يلا حيهم اليوم نستضيف عبد الله الرقيب
مؤسس ايوه وهي شركه متخصصه في بيع
النظارات والعدسات واول شركه نستضيفها في
البرنامج من قطاع البصريات الشركه ما شاء
الله اليوم عندها اكثر من خمسين فرع يغطون
عده دول الخليجيه هذا غير المتجر
الالكتروني والتطبيق طبعا وتعدت مبيعاتها
في 20 22 مئه مليون ريال لكن في بدايه
الحلقه كنت ابي اعرف سبب بدايتهم لبزنس
فيها القطاع في 2017 مع ان في شركات
ومحلات كثير وقتها تبيع احتياجات العملاء
من النظارات وعدسات وغيرها والمثير
للاهتمام انهم بداوا يبيعون النظارات
والعدسات اونلاين فقط وبدون فروع فبنسولف
عن تجربتهم في بيع منتج يفضلون الناس
عادتنا يجربونه قبل يشترونه يبيعونه بس
اونلاين وش التحديات اللي واجهتهم لانهم
بدون فروع بعدها بننتقل لتجربتهم في
التحول من متجر الكتروني يبيع منتجات
متوفره في السوق الى تصنيع منتجاتهم
الخاصه والتحديات والتشريعات المرتبطين في
موضوع التصنيع والاستيراد حق النظارات
والعدسات وغيرها اتكلم برضه عن البراندات
وليس هو براندات خاصه فيهم وما الى ذلك ثم
نتكلم عن تستحمل الفروع بدل ما يكتفون
بالبيع اونلاين وش المشاكل اللي حاولوا
يحلونها من خلال الفروع والتحديات
التشغيليه والتغييرات الكثيره اللي تضروا
يسوونها لانهم تحولوا من شركه تبيع
اونلاين فقط الى شركه بيع اونلاين وعلى
الارض من خلال عده فروع تجاوزت 50 فرع
تغطي السعوديه ودول الخليج وطبعا مغطاه
تفاصيل كثير سواء عن القطاع بشكل عام او
عن عملائهم مثل سبب ارتفاعهم مثل الربح في
النظارات وهل الناس مرتبطين ببرندات معينه
في النظارات ولا يشترون اي شيء كويس ومن
اكبر فئه تشتري في القطاع وكيف اثر دخول
ايوا على السوق والمنافسين بشكل عام حلقه
ثريه جدا في قطاع كنت متحمس صراحه اني
اتعمق في تفاصيله فاترككم معه حياك الله
الله يحييك يا هلا اوقاتك نظاره صراحه
والله
فرصه السوقيه ههه
ايوه لازم نبيع عدسات
المره هذه نعم يلا
لكن احنا بنحطه برومو كود
اكثر منهم ينفذون يمكن يبيعون عليه الحين
لكن يمكن يركزون على
البيع اكثر منهم انهم ينفذون الشيء
ويكونوا مسؤولين عن النتيجه حقته او
يبيعون بعضهم
[موسيقى]
مظلومه شوي يعني ناس فهمتها بطريقه مختلفه
اعتقد ان قطاع يعني مجال
رهيب جدا كتجربه مهنيه ويعتمد بشكل كبير
على انواع المشاريع اللي الواحد شغال فيها
اتكلم على مستوى صفه شخصيه يعني تجربه
يمكن يعني مريت صراحه كذا شركه استشاريه
يمكن مجموع المشاريع خلال فتره سنتين
تقريبا ثمان مشاريع
كانها يعني فتره سنتين بس كنا عن فتره عمل
اربعه الى خمس سنين لانها تكون فتره ضغط
عالي
بعض المشاريع يمكن ست اسابيع او شهرين
ومختلف لا يعتمد على نوع العميل اللي طالب
المشروع بس يكون شغلك في المشروع يصل حتى
للتنفيذ والمتابعه ولا بس انك على حسب على
حسب على حسب نوع العميل يعني اخذها انت
بشكل شخصي انت تقدر يعني ما اقدر الوم
شركه الاستشارات يعني قدر ما لازم برضو
تلوم اللي يطالب العمل اذا ما هو اذا انت
طالب شيء ولا انت فاهم انت طالب ايش يعني
النتيجه بتكون مختلفه اذا انا براجع اكثر
من طبيب وما اعرف انا ايش فيني غير لو انا
عارف بالضبط المشكله اللي عندي علشان واحد
يقدر يعطيك الحل اللي انت فيه
اللي شغالين في شركه
على صفه شخصيه او للعميل لا بصفه شخصيه
هذا انه يجهزك اكثر لانها فيها يعني خلال
العمل
بشكل عام يعني عدد الساعات لو انا بقارن
لك يمكن في الاسبوع عادي انه ممكن تكون
العمل ثمانين ساعه
في ضغط عالي جدا
فيه من خلاله تبني مهارات عاليه جدا لو
ببداها مهارات تحليليه مهارات التواصل
مهارات العرض هذه جدا جدا مهمه ومفيده لك
في سواء في المشروع اللي انت فيه او في اي
عمل اخر بس لو تقول لي في مشاريع كويسه او
مشاريع يمكن ما تطور كثير يعني
على حسب نوع العميل اللي تشتغل معه في
مشاريع يعني تكون تجربتها جدا ممتازه على
حسب يعني البيئه من المدير ايش المطلوب
والمهام
يعني على حسب صلاح يعني اقدر اقول لك من 8
يمكن كان عندي تجربتين ما كانت يعني جدا
مشجعه بس بالمجمل جميله جدا
وتكتسب فيها علاقات مهارات
طريقه التفكير منهجيه التفكير سواء عندك
مشاكل تشغيليه او مشاكل استراتيجيه كل
المهارات هذه قابله للتطبيق في اي قطاعه
تقدر تشتغل فيه حلو اي قطاع فكلها صراحه
تجربتها جدا مفيده يعني لها فائده مره
كبيره في اي عمل ممكن تسويه سواء قطاع خاص
قطاع غير ربحي قطاع حكومي فيها مهارات جدا
ممتازه
والله في ناس تقول كذا وكذا
والله الحقيقه سؤال كويس
القطاع بشكل عام يعني قطاع جدا مشجع يمكن
تتفاجئ لو قلت لك ما في احد من المؤسسين
عنده اي خلفيه او اي خبره من قريب او من
بعيد في مجال البصريات
الكل من خلفيه خبره مجال الاستشارات
وكان يعني
كلنا لنا سابق تجربه في
يعني عمل
مشاريع رياديه
وكلنا اشتغلنا في اكثر من مجال وحسينا
والله ان الفرصه هذه فرصه واحده
المجال
يعني في فجوه كبيره بالسوق وفي نماذج عمل
ناجحه واثبتت نجاحها في اسواق ناشئه
واسواق ناضجه
تقريبا 2017 يعني بس كبدايه عمل تجاري
2018 بس كبدايه التاسيس
واول جوله استثماريه في 2017 2017 في
السوق قاعد تشوف الناس اللي يختمون السوق
في مثلا مغربي المها في مجموعه
في برضو متاجر الله يتصور كانت تبيع وقته
فيه فجوه وفي مشكله في الثلج
قليل جدا الاونلاين هذاك الوقت بس لا
نزالوا الى يومك يعني حتى بعد فتره يعني
اقدر اقول لك ان قطاع مجال البصريات اذا
تقسمها على اكثر من فئه الفئه المنتجات
الغاليه وبجوده عاليه اقدر اقول لك انا
مخدوم جدا يعني مثل اللي تفضلت وغيرهم في
شركات كثير خادمه المجال هذا بنفس الوقت
عندك الاشياء الرخيصه بس برضو جودتها الى
حد ما متدنيه
الفئه اللي بالنص اللي
بجودك كويسه تصاميمها حلوه
عصريه
بسعر مناسب وملائم للجميع يكاد لا يكون
موجود
نادر انك تشوف الشيء هذا في غالبيه
الاسواق اللي خارج سوق المملكه او دول
الخليج اللي احنا شغالين فيها فهذا بين
انه والله في فرصه
كبيره اذا احد دخل المجال هذا ووفر خدمه
ومنتج بسعر مناسب
والله كلنا سابقا كنا في مجال الاستشارات
فنعرف بعض من هذاك الوقت خلاكم تقررون انه
هذه المشكله فعلا
يعني ما هي قصه تقليديه يعني مره ثانيه
لان الكلمه عندها خلفيه في المجال هذا بس
الكل عنده خلفيه في تحليل ودراسات الاسواق
يعني اشتغلنا في اعمال كثير يعني
لعملاء ثانيين يعني عندك نفس القدرات
التحليليه وانك تشوف والله ايش في نماذج
ناجحه اثبتت نجاحها ما هي مطبقه في
المنطقه عندنا نقدر ممكن نطبقها ونقدمها
بطريقه افضل بس اختلافكم عن بعض كلكم
جايين مجال استشارات ولا في واحد مثلا
مركز على الجانب التقنيه واحد مركز على
كذا
الكل الحقيقه مجال الاستشارات بس اقدر
اقول لك يعني كتوزيع وادوار يعني فينا
اللي مركز اكثر من ناحيه يعني
تخصص مالي وجولات استثماريه فينا لتشغيل
اكثر وفينا اكثر بس بشكل عام مكملين لبعض
فالنقاش
مفيده حتى لو تركت مجال الاستشارات
ومع ناس كثير
والله اشياء كثير صراحه يعني كان لست مهام
طويله جدا
يعني
مجال اول شيء انك تاسس موقع ومره سهل انك
يعني كانت البدايه فقط اون لاين مره سهله
انك تاسس موقع بس هو لازم تبحث في السوق
تشوف الناس ايش تطلب ايش ايش اللي في
السوق موجود كيف اقدر اوفره كيف اقدر اطلق
باسرع فرصه لان ما حد عارف اي شيء
باسرع وقت حاولنا نشوف الله ايش اللي
متوفر بالسوق كيف اقدر اعرضه يعني
وبسعر منافس يعني تقدر تجذب فيه تحط عليه
ميزانيه تسويقيه وباسرع وقت وبعدين تبدا
تشوف النتائج وتنصدم
بالواقع بس لازم تكون مثيره سريعه جدا
صراحه بالبدايه لا بدينا بالموجود المحلي
يعني بدينا يمكن تستغرب يمكن تشتري من
يعني اقرب محلات النظارات موجود صور حط
المنتج حط في الموقع حط عليه ميزانيه
تسويقيه وابدا اعرضه وابدا اشوف الله كيف
تقبل العملاء ايش اللي عليه طلب ايش اللي
ما عليه طلب بس انت قاعد بتبيع مهم ما
كانت موجوده المفروض لا كبدايه كبدايه
شغالين في كل شيء كل شيء في مجال البصريات
رهيبه علينا كل شيء قريب علينا بدينا فيه
بس من بعدها تبدا وين المشكله يعني انت
ممكن تتفاجا ان اليوم ايوه تماما مختلفه
عن بدايتها يعني ممكن تستغرب انه اول سنه
ونصف تقريبا اغلبيه مبيعاتنا هي عدسات
لاصقه ما هي لا نظرات شمسيه ولا نظرات
طبيه زي ما هي يعني اقدر اقول لك اللي هي
غالبيه السوق هو يعني اكثر من 80%
النظرات الطبيه
بس تبين لنا بشكل سريع انه والله فعليا
هذه الفجوه الحقيقيه اللي بالسود في ضرب
اكثر على اساس بالضبط تبين ان هذا اكثر
شيء يعني تجربه العميل والتكلفه كانت جدا
عاليه يعني انت عادي انك تروح محل نظرات
والله انا الحين لابس عدسات عادي انك تروح
والله انت ما تقدر تلقى القياس حقك تروح
المحل ما هو موجود سعره غالي تطلبه وبعد
يومين ثلاثه يقول لك تعال استلمه لنا كان
باين جدا انه
موجود عندك المنتج تقدر تشحن على طول
وسعره افضل من اللي موجود في السوق
كانت النتيجه كويسه
فكانت افضل وسيله لجذب العملاء وبنايه انك
تبني قاعده عملاء من خلال
عدد كبير من الناس يبون عدسات منتج
استهلاكي يرجعون يطلبونه اكثر من مره اهو
هذا احد الاسباب بس بالحقيقه برضو يعني ما
عندنا تخصص كافي في النظرات الطبيه
والشمسيه الميزانيه التسويقيه كان اسهل
شيء انك تبدا فيه هو العدسات يعني صار
واضح جدا خلال مساله ايام يعني
لا خلاص صرنا ناخذها من الموزعين لين يعني
زينا زي باقي المحلات من البدايه يعني
خلال فتره اسابيع بسيطه فانتم بديت في كل
المنتجات شفتوا عدسات قاعد تمشي اكثر
بعدين عدسات بالضبط وزادت الوتيره وزادت
بشكل اكبر طبعا بالنظرات الطبيه والشمسيه
بس ما عندك في الحقيقه بالبدايه لمن تشتغل
في كل شيء
ما عندك لا سعر المنافس مره صعب انك
تتنافس بالبدايه ولا عندك
الخبره الكافيه باللي ايش اللي يطلب
المستهلك لان يعني مثل ما تفضلت العدسات
عارف انت ايش قياس النظر عندك عارف ايش
نوعيه العدسه اللي انت متعود عليها فتقدر
تطلبها اكثر من مره ولا في حركه على وجهي
بالنظرات ما حد فينا عندها الخلفيه هذه
يعني انت عندك
مخاطره كبيره
بالمنتجات اللي لازم توفرها ايش
العمله يطلبونه بس هذا بنين القاعده مع
الوقت والتكرار وكذا محاوله بس كان مبدئيا
يعني عشرات الاف العملاء اللي قدرنا اول
مره نخدمهم اكثر من 90% منهم عدسات وكلهم
كنت تستحون عليهم من خلال القنوات
مثل الانستغرام سناب شات فيسبوك وغيره
وبرضو من خلال يعني قنوات المؤثرين وغيرها
فقعدت تقريبا وانتم على هالنموذج ان شاء
في
عدسات الموزعين ونظرات من المنافسين يعني
تقريبا اول احنا اول شيء لنزال شغالين
يعني في العدسات واشياء غيرها لا نزال
المستمرين فيها بس مع الوقت
يعني في اقدر اقول لك في مجال الاونلاين
ثقافه انك دائما في تكرار دائما انك تجرب
اشياء مختلفه
تبني على النتيجه فيها
وتكرر منها تبدا بعد خلينا نقول بعد ما
تخدم عشره الاف 15 الف عميل خلاص انت تعرف
والله ايش الستايل اللي يناسب الناس ايش
اللون المناسب فاعرف ايش اللي مناسب اني
اطلب منه اذا انت توك بادي مره صعب انك
تقول والله تدري اقدر انا جاهز اني اتعامل
مع مصنع ابى اعممن طلبيه بالعدد خطره جدا
كبيره انك تسويها من اول يوم بس مع الوقت
باللي موجود باللي متوفر تقدر يعني مع
الوقت تشوف ايش اللي مناسب للعملاء وهذه
مثلا الفتره الثانيه اللي بدينا فيها اللي
بعد ما صار عندنا فهم اكثر
وصلنا النتيجه ان غالبيه الموجود في السوق
اللي عارفينها قبل يعني بس
من الصعب انك تتنافس فيه ولا هو اللي نحس
فعلا فيه الفجوه الحقيقيه يعني
مخدومه بشكل جدا جيد بس اللي سعر بالنص ما
هو مخدوم يعني على شو يقول واضح باللي من
سعر 200 الى 400 ريال مره صعب انك تلقاه
عادي اللي تلقاه فوق 600 700 ريال عادي
تلقى اللي في محطات بنزين
بس اللي في النص منتج
بجوده كويسه تصميم جميل
يكاد لا يكون مخدوم
يعني من الاساس ركزنا عليه وكان ممكن انك
تتنافس فيه بشكل جيد
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
موضوع هو مرتبط بها ومش الربح العاليه جدا
في السوق سوق نظارات تحديدا يعني ممكن تصل
الى 80% بشيء يعني وبخلق فيه صراحه عالميا
اتكلم حتى لدرجه
كانت تفاصيل الخبر سابقا كان فيه احد امه
مصنعين نظارات النظارات كان يحاول يستحول
على اي احد جديد يطلع على اساس خلاص انه
يبدا يمتلك السوق بشكل كامل لانه
ملزم ماديا جدا
اتمنى لو اشوف اي شركه موجود كثير
يعني ما عندنا في المنطقه بس عالميا ما في
امثله شفتها تصل للهواء مش هذي
ممكن يعني ممكن في اشياء معينه بس كمجمل
لا من الصعب
ولو اخذنا حتى اللي شغالين في القطاع هذا
حتى المنتجات الثمينه بالحقيقه صعب انك
تكون منافس فيها لان اذا شفت سلسله
الامداد بالمنتج هذا
خليني اقول يعني عبد الله ومشهور مسوي محل
نظارات
انت ما راح تشتري من المصنع دايركت راح
تشتري من موزع موزع بياخذه من وكيل وكيل
بياخذه من خلينا نقول اكبر الشركات
العالميه اللي تدفع حق امتياز الاستخدام
احد البرانز العالميه فانت في الحقيقه
قاعد تمر على اكثر من شخص وكل واحد يعني
شغال في البزنس ولازم يكون يعني مجدي
الاستثمار فيه
تدفع يعني هذا احد الاسباب اللي السعر
عالي فاحنا مثلا المنتج ليش اقول لك جوده
اللي نقدمه عاليه ان اليوم نتعامل مع اكبر
المصانع اللي تصنع للشركات الغاليه بس
قادرين انه نوفر بثلث السعر
ولا يزال يظل عندنا هامش جيد
نتكلم فيه الهواء مش قد لا تصل يمكن 80%
بالمجمل لكنها عاليه جدا يعني ممكن خلنا
نقول كم يعني ممكن تكون
تتفاوت وفي السوق بشكل عام
لو انا مثلا الان لابس عدسات بعض العدسات
اللي ممكن نبيعها ما نربح فيها اكثر من
30% او 35% هامش في منتجات كل ما زادت
تفصيل
برضو على حسب يعني احنا النظرات عندنا
بتبدا من 400 ريال وداخله فيها العدسه
وعدسه بجوده عاليه بس نتكلم عنكم يعني على
حسب بس يعني لو انا اخذت مره ثانيه من
السوق بعض اللي لان الان يعني حجم عملنا
كبير قادرين اننا نتعامل بشكل مباشر مع
المصنع فغير من اللي في السوق لا مو بالكل
شغل
يعني يرجع لسلسله
فيها اكثر من شخص فبالاخير يعني ما حيكون
عنده يعني يمكن لو تعامل بسعر عالي مع
المصنع بشكل مباشر نعم ممكن انها تصل
في السوق مو بالشكل كم بنكمل
ربح يعني من خمسين الى اللي بالمجمل اذا
اخذته بعد يعني تصفيه مخزون وغيره وكذا
تلقاهم في الخمسين بالمئه
يعني اقدر اقول لكم مقارب لقطاع
اللي يستهدف نوعيه العملاء اللي عندك فهذه
برضو فرصه ثانيه لاحد الاشياء اللي خلتنا
نتشجع من البدايه اننا نبدا نطور ونبني
براند مناسبه
للفئه ثقافه المجتمع اللي احنا على
البرونز بس الان
كتسعير او اليه تسعير عندكم هل انت تقلل
في التكلفه او انك مثلا في سلسله
مثلا المصنع تحاول
متوسط
ولا ايا كان الشخص اللي في نهايه سلسله
ولا بروح المصنع مباشره وش طريقه الطريق
الاستخدام عشان تقلل في السعر وتصير في
النص ما بين المنتج الرخيص والمنتج الغالي
يعني بهدفنا اننا نقدم المنتج بسعر منافس
الطريقه اللي شغالين فيها باننا نتعامل
غالبيه المنتجات الان اللي نقدمها نتعامل
بشكل مباشر مع المصنع فنرجع لسلسله
الامداد
حلو طيب بنرجع الحين للمرحله الاولى قلت
انتهيتوا منها وتعلمتوا انه العدسات يمكن
هي كانت اكثر شيء رائج تعلمتوا ايضا
النظارات سعرها غاليه وتكلفتها غاليه
تعلمتوها مرحله الاولى
فهم اكثر للعميل ايش اللي يعني بالرغم من
ان انا اشتغلنا على جميع الشرائح فهم اكثر
ايش اللي اللي يناسب العملاء عندك فتقدر
تطور المنتج او تشتري المنتج اللي يناسب
الفئه اللي عندك حلو
بدينا خطوه الان اليوم لو شفت تحت ايوه
عندنا ثمان علامات تجاريه مسجله او يعني
في طور التسجيل غالبيتها تمس اكثر من
شريحه في منتجات البصريات يعني عندنا
للنظرات الطبيه شيل للاطفال شيل الكبار
النظرات الشمسيه عندنا فئتين فئه اللي
يعني خلينا نقول
سعرها حتى منافس اكثر من
يعني خلينا نقول كل شهر وحول ممكن ينزل
كولكشن جديد اللي اغلى شوي يعني خلينا
نقول تصميمه ومورك كلاسيك وجوده اعلى
بعدين برضو اطلقنا كذا براند في العدسات
اللاصقه العدسات الشفافه الملونه الزينه
يعني كل كذا شهر يعني نبدا الخطوات بس
نبداها ما نبداها بشكل كبير يعني خلال ما
احنا نطلقها قاعدين نتعلم وقاعدين نزيد وش
كانت الكيف كان طريق انك تبدا برامج في
النظارات وليش اصلا سويت الخطوه هذه هل
كان سؤال كويس اضطرينا اننا نسويها مره
ثانيه لان السوق ما هو يعني كثير منا ما
هو متوفر يعني لو بتشتري محلي غالبيه
الموجود سعره مره غالي فصعب جدا انك
تتنافس فيه يعني ممكن تبداه كبدايه تتعلم
منه بس ما هو يعني طريقه مستدامه ما تقدر
يعني تستمر انك تكون خسران انك تاخذ منتج
تكلفته غاليه وتبيعه بسعر رخيص ما كان
ضروري انك تبدى بهالشيء هذا بس مع الوقت
بعد ما عرفت والله ايش الرائج ايش الماشي
ايش اللي الناس تتفضله
وصار عندك قاعده بيانات وعملاء اكثر تقدر
تاخذ المخاطره انك تعرف ايش اللي ماشي ايش
الرائج اقدر اتعامل الان مع مصنع
يوفر المنتج يعني اقدر عندي الكميه
الكافيه اللي تقدر تاخذها وتقدر تصرفها
وانت مرتاح في المرحله الثانيه دخلت في
التعامل مع المصانع لتصنيع النظارات
بالضبط طبعا خلال الفتره هذه بنينا فريق
كبير متخصص في المجال هذا عارفين يعني
وين افضل الاماكن اللي تقدر تورد منها
وتكون بجوده عاليه حلو التعامل مع المصانع
الان كنتم تعملون لتصنيع العدسات
والعدسات اللاصقه والنظارات كل هذا كل شيء
قطاع يعني
المصانع المتخصصه والرائده في العدسات
اللاصقه شيء واللي متميز في مجال مثلا
اطارات النظارات شيء بس قصدي كلها تصنعونه
يعني ما في او تتعاملوا
نعم طبعا لا نزال للتوضيح نتعامل مع كل
الشركات ولا نزال نتعامل مع الكل يعني
نشتري من الموردين نشتري مع موزعين نشتري
معه لكن كتركيز اقدر اقول لك مثلا ايوه
قادر انها يتميز فيه متوفر شيء مختلف هو
عن طريق المنتجات اللي احنا نوفرها من
خلال التعاملنا مباشر يعني الاشياء اللي
في متناول الجميع وعليها طلب
والزبون يطلبها اكيد هذه نوفرها ولكن
الاشياء اللي حسينا اللي من البدايه وين
في فجوه بالعرض وين ممكن نتميز فيه هي
الاشياء اللي
حسينا من المهم اننا نتميز فيها ونوفرها
وش اللي خليكم تقولون هذا بنسوي البراند
خاص ما يصير يعني ضمن اسم ثاني والله سؤال
كويس بصراحه يعني
دخلنا في نقاش مره طويل
سؤال استراتيجي هل تحط كل شيء تحت اسم
ايوه
او انك تقول والله
اذا عملت طبعا من ناحيه ثانيه بيكون اسهل
اسهل من ناحيه كفاءه يمكن للتسويق اسهلك
من انك تسوق كذا منتجات بس بنفس الوقت
فئه عن فئه تختلف فمره صعب انك يعني كويس
انه كل براند اللي
يحاكي شريحه معينه انه يكون متميز ومتخصص
فيها
يعني فبالتالي بالطريقه للكل براند ممكن
يكون له هويته له روح له قصه
يعني قادر انه يكون ناجح
سواء هو داخل يباع داخل ايوه او خارج ايوه
يعني
حاليا سبعه
وليس مثلا ثلاثه لانكم عندكم سبع فئات
تستهدفونهم
فكل فئه تستهدفون يعني مثلا لو انا اخذت
مثلا خليني اقول انت اخذت نظاره طبيه
انت تقدر يعني الاطار شيء والعدسه شيء اخر
العدسه اللي للنظاره وفي انواع كثير
وفيئات مختلفه وباسعار متفاوته وكثير منها
اسعارها غاليه فاحنا حسينا والله عارف انت
تقدر تقدم نفس الجوده بشكل مره عالي اذا
انت قدرت انك
تتعامل بشكل مباشر مع المصنع ويصنع لك بدل
ما انت ترجع مره ثانيه للاكثر من وكيل
وموزع وبتخليه مثلا اذا هو براند حق يكون
اسمه كيوت يكون بالضبط
في تطوير اشياء ولها علاقه فبيكون مثلا لو
اخذنا باسم ايوه مره صعب وشوي مشتت للعميل
انك تدخل بنفس الاسم باكثر من شيء يعني
تخيل لو معليش على المقارنه المختلفه بس
تخيل انت مطعم
مره صعب يكون عندك قائمه وانت عندك مندي
وايطالي وبيتزا وبرك مره صعب بس اسهل لك
انك يكون عندك مثلا شيء متخصص فيه مثلا كل
فئه عندك اللي انت توفرها كمنت
انت الان في فانت تحط كل جهدك التسويقي في
تسويق البراندات هذه مو في تسويق اكيد
عندك ميزانيه لتسويق ايوه
المنصه او المتجر اللي ممكن تمر عليه
وتلقى فيه
جميع منتجات البصريات اللي تناسبك وبرضو
اكيد في ميزانيه تسويقيه للكل فئه من
الشغلين فيها حلو الان تتعامل مع المصنع
عشان تصنع نظاره اعرف اوكي وش يصير هناك
اتصور طبعا في حد ادنى النظارات على اساس
يقدر خط انتاج وتقدر تشتغل فيها
بتحتاج انت الان اذا بتسوي مجموعه نظارات
ناسب مختلفه
واذواق متعدده اكيد من تجربتكم في المرحله
الاولى اكتشفتوا في اشياء عليها طلب قليل
مشاعر يا طلب كثير اشياء عليها يمكن طلب
مئه في المئه وزنها مع المصنع وانت تطلب
الكميات هذه بالبدايه للامان ما اشتغلنا
على طول مع مصانع يعني حتى بدينا نشتغل مع
موردين للبرانز ما كان لها حتى يعني
اسعارها مناسبه بس ما لها وجود في السوق
بدينا يعني باسعار نفس الاسعار اللي احنا
شغالين فيها يعني اقدر اقول لك الامانه
تعلمنا منها اكثر بكثير لانها مالها وجود
في السوق تقدر تاخذها بسعر منافس تقدر
تكون تقدر تبني عليها استراتيجيه يعني
تجرب فيها اكثر وتبني فيها قاعده عملاء
اكثر وبعدها يعني وصلنا الى حجم تقدر تعمل
فيه مع مصانع طبعا في بعضهم مصانع اصغر
ممكن انك يعني تبدا بس انها ما تكون يعني
تكون خطوه خطوه يعني مع الوقت جرب وممكن
تجرب في اشياء مختلفه بس مع الوقت طبعا
تتعلم من يعني وتيره يعني ايش اللي نجحت
فيه ايش اللي اخطات فيه
يعني تطوير المنتج عمل لا ينتهي بس
تركيزكم في التعامل مع مصانع الاشياء اللي
لها رواج كبير عشان تضمنون
مره ثانيه زي حجم سوق الازياء او الملابس
والفاشن متغير ففي اشياء كل شوي يعني ممكن
يعني تجرب وتنزل في اشياء جديده مختلفه
الاستيراد من المصانع هل في اشتراطات ما
في شك يعني احنا مجال الجهه التشريعيه
يعني مئه بالمئه احنا في قطاع
منظم بشكل عالي جدا يعني تحت تنظيم وزاره
الصحه هيئه الغذاء والدواء هذه تعتبر
منتجات طبيه حتى العدسات اللاصقه يعتبر
منتج طبي الشمسيه
لان هذا برضو في يو في بروتكشن يعني
فيعتبر برضه
يعتبر يعني يعني ما تقدر انت اليوم انا
بعمل سجل تجاري بستورد لا تحت انك تاخذ
تصاريح من هيئه الغذاء والدواء
انك تكون يعني مورد لمنتجات المصريات لازم
يكون عندك يعني
المعمل والبيئه المناسبه
والاليات المناسبه اللي تقدر تتعامل فيها
مع المصانع مو اي مصنع تقدر يعني تشتغل
معاه لازم يكون عنده مرخص يكون عنده
شهادات الايزو وغيرها يعني يعني ما تشتغل
معي احد هذه منتجات بالاخير طبيه ومهم
يعني الجوده فيها تكون عاليه نحط بالعين
يعني 100% بس في اشتراطات على المواد نفس
المستخدمه سواء في الاطار سواء في العدس
يعني 100% نحرص مره ثانيه لتوفير منتج
بجوده عاليه يعني ما يكون اللي تلقاه في
محطه البنزين بس هل هو ههه ان شاء الله
اتمنى شيء احيانا تروح
شمسيه بخمسه ريال يعني
وهذه النقطه تروح المحلات يعني محلات اخرى
تشوف انه يقول لك هذه تحمي من مدري وش
وهذه مدري ايش بس أنا هل هذا التسويق ولا
فعلا قاعد يعني بيعطيني فوائد طبيه اللي
قاعد يدعيها في الشمسيه تحديدا
في كذا وفي كذا
بس لا يعني انه يكون عندك جدا مهم الحمايه
من اشعه الشمس جدا مهمه واقدر اقول لك من
تجربه شخصيه كنت مع احد جاء يعني يعني
يتعرض لما كان لابس وما كان عند الحمايه
الكافيه ياثر على ولا يعني افضل انك
تستشير طبيب بسويقي
يعني العين جدا مهمه ولازم الواحد يحرص
انه يستخدم المنتج المناسب
هل في جانب تسويقي ممكن نعم يعني ما يحتاج
انك تدفع
الاف علشان يكون عندك شيء هذا لا ممكن
يعني ب 3400 عادي انك يعني تصل للجوده
المناسبه ويكون فيها الحمايه بس هل هو
يسير عليكم تدقيق زي مثلا القطاعات
الثانيه بالكرسي اللي عينه من النظاره اي
اكيد ما في تستورد اي شيء اللي عندك
متطلبات كثيره ويتم لها
ايا كان فيه وفيه على حسب التوريد على حسب
ما تتركبت في اشياء ممكن تتركب لاحقا يعني
لها لها تفاصيل وكثير يعني تخزين العدسات
ما في شك يعني مره ثانيه هذه منتجات طبيه
اي شيء تتعامل معها يعني
على سبيل المثال العدسات اللاصقه يعني
يعتبر كانك تقول منتج طبي ما يكفي بس رقم
الصنف ايش الباتش نمبر تاريخ التصنيع مثل
كلها مهمه واكيد لازم تكون يعني في حال لا
سمح الله صار اي شيء ممكن يعني هيئه
الغذاء والدواء تستقبل بلاغات يصير تعميم
اذا في شيء لازم يسحب او غيره يعني مره
ثانيه هذا المنتج يستخدم للعين
الجوده مهمه فيه ولها اشتراطات مختلفه عن
قطاعات اخرى لحتى طريقه في موضوع التوصيل
المستهلك النهائي ولا اذا يعني بعد ما يصل
المنتج داخل المملكه لامر اخر يعني خلاص
انت لان من الاساس ما يكون الا شركه بدت
وعندها تراخيص اللازمه في انها تمارس هذا
النشاط بس انا اطلب من برا ويجيني اونلاين
قصدي اطلب مثلا وفي مندوب بيوصله ما في
اشتراط على انه لا هذه عدسات ما تنقل او
عدسات لاصقه ما تنقلها زي العدسات العاديه
لان هذه ممكن تاثر بالحر ولا ايا كان يعني
اكيد احنا ما نستخدم الاماكن المبرده نتبع
ارشادات درجه الحراره لازم تكون فيها لا
اكيد مهمه حلو وكلها يعني متبعه
بالعكس الجهات الرقابيه والتنظيميه يعني
قائمين بدور يعني عالي جدا جدا في هذا
المجال لجميع الةةة تدور حول صناعه
البراندات والتصنيع والامور هذي كلها
فالمرحله الاولى كانت تنقل انت قلت من
2017 يعني كان خلينا نقول الكبدايه عمل
تجاري تبيعه وتربح فيه 2018 2018 2017
اخرها كثير منها تجارب بس كريم البزنس
يعني
تقريبا سنه ونص بدينا قبل كورونا ببدايه
البراند يعني فتره كورونا تقدر تقول يعني
فتره ثانيه
يعني
استمر وتيره النمو فيها على قد ما هي فتره
صراحه يعني متعبه للكثير على قد ما كانت
يعني فرصه مناسبه للعلاقه كوننا شركه
اونلاين يعني متجر وتطبيق الكتروني
فهذا خدمنا بشكل مره كبير بس الفتره
الاولى من 2018 الى كم كانت
يعني لين ما بدينا اطلاق براند خليني اقول
لك من منتصف الى اخر 2019 حلو فمن 2019
بدات تصنعون البراندات بالضبط الى متى
بدات المرحله الثالثه
يعني اقدر اقول لك المرحله الثالثه اللي
بدينا فيها خلينا نقول لمن بدينا اطلقنا
اول متجر لايوه
يعني نزلنا من
صرنا اوف لاين وصار عندنا اول ستور
محلات يعني الناس الحين توجهون بالعكس
بس قبل ما ادخل فيها ودي اتكلم عن تجربه
العميل مع الشباب نظاره اونلاين انا من
الناس اللي ما اثق ودائما اقرا تعرف
المقاسات هذه على النظاره عشان تشوف طول
مدري ويش شو طول قريت انا والله اروح
المحلات اجربها ما تضبط
المقاسات حقت النظاره بس ما تركب على
الوجه يعني اوكي تجي بس صحيح
بس من طرفنا عملنا صراحه استثمارات مره
كثير لا قدر الامكان تبسيط العمليه هذه
كيف قدرتوا تكسبون ثقه العميل فانه يشتري
نظاره ما جربها
اول شيء يعني نحاول قدر الامكان تبسيط
العمليه باعلى درجه يعني حتى العميل اللي
ما هو عارف ممكن انه حتى يكمل الطلبيه
وممكن خدمه العملاء يساعدوه في معرفه
بالضبط القياسات عنده نحاول القدره
الامكان يعني تجربه العميل تكون باسهل ما
يمكن
الاستبدال الترجيع يعني 30 يوم يعني ممكن
العميل ياخذ الطلب بدون ما يكون متخوف انه
والله
الشركه هذه خذت الفلوس وما سويتها زي ما
اسم متاجر العطورات اونلاين اللي ضمان
ذهبي تقريبا جرب تقريبا الى حد ما عملنا
طبعا اشياء كثير بدانا تقدر انت بنفسك
تجرب النظاره عليك تشوف اذا هي تناسبك ايش
مقاس وجهك يعني قاعدين نستثمر بشكل كبير
في المجال هذا
فكره والله يعني تعطيك فكره بس مع الوقت
يعني
قاعده تتطور بشكل مره كبير
نسبه ارجاع عاليه من الاول كم سنه قبل ما
تفتحون المحل
والله ممكن تنصدم ما هو بنسبه الارجاع
اللي تتخيلها
يعني ما هي
متدنيه اقل بكثير من المشاكل اللي كانوا
يواجهونها في التعامل مع محل البصريات او
متجر بصريات فقط وقتها يعني ابرز المشاكل
وش كانت كعميل ايش ابرز المشاكل التي
تواجهني اني اشتري
نظارات وعدسات اونلاين ممتاز الحقيقه يعني
الوقت اللي بدينا فيه مره قليل جدا اللي
ممكن تلقى احد متخصص في هذا المجال يعني
ممكن في ناس تبيع عدسات بس ما تبيع نظارات
او غيرها يعني ممكن انك تشتريها من
الاماكن ثانيه ممكن اني اخذها القاها على
يعني ماركه نون ولا بس ما تحس ان الموقع
هذا مصمم ومخصص لتقديم يعني حتى لما خلينا
نقول انا بحتاج اختار قياس النظر نفس
تصميم الموقع الالكتروني والتطبيق ما يخدم
الخاصيه هذه تخيل انك تحتاج تحط تنتقل الى
اكثر من صفحه علشان تدور
العلبه والشيء الفلاني اللي يناسبك ما هي
يعني ما هو مصمم بطريقه سهله وسلسه
المنصات هذه
مصممه لمئات الالاف من المنتجات ما هي
مصممه انها تقدر توفر فيها منتجات
البصريات بطريقه سهله وسريعه فما كنت تحس
فيه مشاكل خاصه فيكم مقارنه بالمحل بالمحل
يمكن اللي وفرناه اننا يعني حاولنا نسويها
بطريقه مره سهله ممكن خلال اقل من دقيقه
تعمل الطلبيه طب وش تفتح
جدا ممتاز السؤال يعني قعدنا يمكن فتره
ثلاث سنين تقريبا اللي
بدون ما نجرب اي شيء ما اخفيك قبل بدايه
كورونا يعني الحمد لله وتيره النمو استمرت
بشكل عالي الحمد لله يعني جدا كبير
زي ما قلت لك بالبدايه درسنا نماذج كثيره
في السوق
وشفنا انه كثير من اللي بدو اونلاين
وبعدين يعني اطلقوا بداوا كافرع خدمهم
بشكل مره كبير يعني لا تنسى المجال اللي
احنا فيه
كمجال منخفض مقارنه لو انا في عطور او
يعني
تجميل او ازياء
والله يعني مره يعني اذا انت ما عندك فحص
النظر اسهل لك بكثير انك توفر الخدمه هذه
طبعا بالنسبه لنا حقيقه بدات كتجربه
بالبدايه ما اخفيك كان في تخوف جدا عالي
لان درسنا يعني في الخارج شفنا نماذج لعمل
ناجحه بس لما درسنا سوق في الداخل الحقيقه
كان في يعني قصص الفشل اكثر من النجاح هذه
كانت جدا جدا مخوفتنا
يعني بدون ذكر اسماء بس يعني شركات كبير
متخصصه في التجزئه دخلت في المجال هذا
وكثير منهم رائدين ولا استمروا واطلعوا
فكانت هذه شوي خوفتنا هل هم كانوا مثلا
موزعين وقرروا يفتحوا المحلات بس خلينا
نقول يعني عندهم امتياز تجاري ماخذين
وكالات معينه متخصصين في مجالات متعدده
كان حق امتيازه وفران شايز فتحوه وما
استمر طبعا الاسباب الفشل المتعدده فاحنا
لما يعني دخلنا في التفاصيل اكثر
حسينا ان اللي عندنا شويه مختلف
يعني اسباب متعدده مره ثانيه لان ما فيه
شيء مختلف يعني نفس المنتجات اللي تلقاها
باسعار عاليه ونفس البرنت المعروفه السعر
ما في اي تميز الهواء مش عندهم مو زي اللي
انت تتوقعه يعني مره ثانيه لو الهواء مش
جدا عالي يمكنهم ما قفلوا صعب التميز فيه
والتخصص مطلوب في هذا المجال عنده وكاله
براند واحد مثلا فهو حد نفسه فعليا وما
راح يكون عنده نفس المرونه اللي يشتغل مع
مجموعه براندات بها اوامر ويمكن ما يكون
متخصص في المجال هذا بس على اي حال وضعنا
كان جدا مختلف لان يعني عندك تمس شريحه
مختلفه سعر مختلف منتجك مختلف فالشي هذا
صراحه شجعنا وبدايه بدات كتجربه يعني اقدر
اقول لك لو بدينا كان من الصعب انك تبدا
من البدايه لا عندك اصلا المخزون ما عندك
الخلفيه ما تعرف الزبون ايش اللي محتاجه
بس بعد ثلاث سنين يعني بالضبط يمكن تقول
انكم تحسون مختلفين عن تجارب الفاشله هذه
لان المنتجك سعره ثلث سعرهم فالسعر مختلف
الجوده يعني الخدمه العميل المختلفه تماما
كثير من
يعني اللي بدو
مجال البصريات يعني طريقتنا نقدم بطريقه
عصريه مختلفه هو يتعامل معك مريض عندك
مشكله يعني صحيه
بيقابلك حد لابس كود ابيض يلا نفحص نظرك
احنا نتعامل معاه بطريقه جدا مختلفه يعني
اللبسه جزء من هويتك انا يعني ايش اللي
البسها بجد مهم فاحنا يعني يمكن اذا شفت
يعني الطريقه اللي نتعامل فيها مع العميل
جدا مختلفه من خلينا نقول يعني غالبيه
البزنس التقليديه يعني
من الناحيه هذه مختلفه اخذنا وقتنا صراحه
كنا ناويين نبدا ابكر شوي بس فتره كورونا
عندك مئات محلات البصريات اللي قفلت
فاضطرينا نستثمر فيها بشكل اكبر
وزعنا مستودعاتنا واستمر بشكل اقوى عشان
اكون قبل ما اتكلم عن تاسيس المحل الفجوه
اللي كنت اكبر فجوه تغطونها من خلال
وجودكم على الارض في محل
هي الحقيقه نفس الاشكاليه اللي موجوده
اونلاين كمتجر وتطبيق الكتروني هي برضو
موجوده في الارض الواقع
اكتشفنا اننا قاعدين نحل نفس المشكله يعني
مع الوقت يعني على سنتنا الثالثه
كثير من العملاء يسالون فروعكم وين لانك
انت اون لاين يفترض انك عندك محلات بس
قصدي المحلات مثلا موضوع فحص النظر ما في
شك 100% بس انت قادر
جزء كبير مثل ما تفضلت انك قادر انك يعني
العميل اول شيء يثق فيك قادر انه يعمل فحص
نظر بشكل سهل قادر انه يجرب المنتج يعني
صحيح فيه بالتطبيق او غيره تقدر تجرب
بالموبايل بس مره غير انك يعني تلبسه
الشيء فاكيد الشي هذا يعني يساعد لما
بدينا بدايتنا مختلفه يعني كثير من
الزبائن اللي عندنا قبل لا يزور المحل
يكون زار التطبيق قبل شاف بعض المنتجات
فافضل انه يمكن نجربها على ارض الواقع فوش
غيرت قلت له على المستودعات عشان تبدا
تاسسون اول فرع
يعني حجمنا اقدر اقول لك قبل ما نبدا اول
فرع يعني وصل كحجم اون لاين لو ابقارنه
بمبيعات يعني حجمها كان مو بسيط يعني عن
كانك تقول ما يقل عن 30 اربعين فرع
كحجم متجر الكتروني
بالحقيقه ما صار تغيير كثير يعني لما
بدينا اول فرق كان كميه تجارب لا تنتهي بس
ما اشترينا بضاعه مختلفه علشان هو الفرق
يعني كان عندك ردي المنتجات موجوده قبل ما
الفرق كم كانت بعدكم سنويه تقريبا او اخر
سنه قبل ما تبداون البرع بدون رقم دقيق
يعني بس احتاج بشكل عام يعني قبل لا نفتح
اول فرع يعني كمجمل المبيعات يعني لو
اخذنا من بدينا لين قبل ما نفتح اول فرع
لا تجاوز اكثر من 50 مليون يعني عندك كميه
قاعده بيانات عارف العملاء ايش يحبون ايش
يناسبهم وعندك كميه مخزون كافيه انك تقدر
تقول يعني يعني وصلنا مرحله انه يعني حتى
لو لا سمح الله فشل فشل التجربه ما في
مشكله تقدر تستمر اونلاين يعني ما هي ما
كانت بحجم استثمار زي انت توك بادي وليش
قررت بجنب فرعون مثلا كجزء من صيدليه ولا
جزء من
جدا ممتازه السؤال الحقيقه فكرنا بنماذج
مختلفه هذه ارخص بكثير انك تبداها بس
فضلنا انك تبدا بطريقه صحيحه مناسبه
المجال هذا مرخص من وزاره الصحه لازم يكون
عندك الفاحص لازم تاخذي التراخيص المناسبه
وبرضو لازم تعطي التجربه حقها لانه اذا
بديت كذا على استحياء او ما يكون بالشكل
المناسب صعب انك تبني القرار الصحيح يعني
انت ممكن تقول نفرض مثلا
انا محل داخل محل يمكن يفشل بس ما له دخل
انك يعني
من عوامل لها علاقه بالضبط لازم يكون كويس
عندكم كاش تقدر تجرب يعني اكيد يعني وضع
مختلف وضع المختلف كثيرا شركات عندنا دعم
غير طبيعي الحمد لله من كثير من الشركه
والمستثمرين معنا الاول الفرع وين قررت
تفتحونه اول فرع فتحناه في الظهران مول في
يعني قريب على
قريب علينا
المكتب خمس دقائق فقلنا يعني اول تجربه
كويسه نكون
وما قصروا صراحه معنا يعني كانت فتره مره
تخوف يعني ما ادري اذا الناس تتذكر بس ترى
يعني سنه 2020 سنه مخيفه جدا
مؤلمه ومخيفه جدا ومتعبه بس بنفس الوقت
على قد ما انه كثير كان في تخوف وفي احجام
يعني
[موسيقى]
سابقا المراكز العربيه الان سنومي صراحه
دعمهم كان غير طبيعي ومشجعين لنا بشكل مره
كبير والحمد لله يعني كانت بدايه جدا
موفقه عوف فتحتوه زي اي يعني كفكره جمالا
زي اي محل نظارات اللهم حاولنا مره ثانيه
نقدمها بطريقه مختلفه يعني
مريض
يعني نوعيه المنتجات اللي اذا دخلت محل
ايوه اليوم راح اضمن لك انها 80% مختلفه
عن اي محل نظارات بتشوفه ثاني
كسعر مختلف تماما اول تجربه عندكم
نعم وصلنا عندنا عشر محلات في الامارات
انا دخلت اول محل
وكانت تجربه غريبه صراحه
حسيتها كذا
غير مالوفه اللي داخل المكان محل نظارات
صحيح
لان غالبيه محلات النظرات اذا اخذت
بالمجمل كذا محلات اللمبه بيضاء الارفف
بيضه
وكلهم يتشابهون لو غيرت اسم المحل من برا
ما تدري انت في اي واحد كلهم نفس الشيء
صراحه استثمرنا وقت وجهد مره كبير اخذنا
وقتنا في وقت كورونا اشتغلنا مع المصممين
وقلنا نبي
نقدم الشيء بطريقه مختلفه
تغير من ناحيه يعني
صدقا يعني
كانك تبني الشركه مره ثانيه لانه نوعيه
المهارات اللي تحتاجها نوعيه العرض اللي
تحتاجه
نوعيه
التسوق العميل تختلف يعني ممكن اذا انت
على متجر الكتروني الناس
يهمهم السعر بشكل اكبر اذا انت في يعني في
المحل فعليا على ارض الواقع يعني مختلف
التصرف العميل انه يرتبط عاطفيا يعني وحتى
لو انت عملت يعني استبيان وشفت
تصرف الفرد يختلف يعني
اعطيك مثلا مثال بسيط
في العدسات اللاصقه اعمل يعني اعمل
الصبيان ايش يهمك اكثر الجوده السعر
[موسيقى]
يعني سرعه التوصيل يعني
الكل بيقول الجوده بس لما نشوف اونلاين
تلقى تصرف العميل يختار اللي سعره اقل مع
انه يبي الجوده الكويسه بس بيختار اللي
سعره اقل في الدخل المحل لا فعلا ياخذ
اللي بالجوده اعلى وسعرها اعلى
لان تعرف لما انت تكون على ارض الواقع
تتعامل مع بني ادم وشات بوت فل روبوت ولا
يعني بتتعامل مع اخصائي ويشرح لك اكيد
يختلف ايضا تشغيله من غير
طريقه العرض طريقه التسعير طريقه شرح
المنتج طريقه عرضه
يعني ايش اللي يناسب اكثر ايش المساحه
اللي يعني
تفكيرك يكون مختلف يعني طريقه الفريق اللي
شغال في
المتخصص في قسم المنتجات طريقه العمل
ايش اللي يصلح ايش المنتج اللي اعرضه
اونلاين يختلف عن الطريقه ايش اللي يناسب
اعرضه
تختلف المهارات اللي مطلوبه
ايش اللي
يناسب يكون اونلاين وايش اللي يناسب يكون
اوفلاين وايش اللي التركيز عليه اكثر
المهارات مين مهارات الفريق القائم على
المنتجات
الاختلاف من ناحيه المحله والمنتجات
المنتجات قلت لي ذكرت موضوع السعر اللي
ينباع في الفروع اعلى سعرا من اللي ينباع
في الغالب غالبيتها نفس الشيء فكيف نفس
السعر ممكن يكون
ترويجيه تختلف بس تكون برضه في الافرع نفس
الشيء بس يعني
لان حجم الاونلاين اكبر بكثير ما تقدر
تعرض كل البضاعه اللي في المحل فالمحل في
الغالب موجود فيه اكثر الاشياء اللي رائج
وعليه طلب بس وش اللي ياثر على السعر في
المحل
يكون نفس السعر بس ممكن في الاون لاين
يكون مثلا عروض ترويجيه اكثر يعني يوم
وطني يوم كذا يوم هذا ممكن انه
التخفيضات اللي تفيد تكون تختلف يعني
ولا ينطبق علينا فقط يعني غالبيه قطاع
التجزئه بالعاده دائما العميل اللي يتسوق
يعني
يمه اكثر حساسيه السعر عنده اعلى بكثير من
اللي بيكون يعني
حاب يشتري المنتج
مختلفه تؤثر على التسعير بين الاونلاين
مثلا نقول في الاوف لاين في ايجار المحل
في رواتب الموظفين كذا كذا فهذه ممكن ياثر
على الاسعار الاون لاين ممكن الموضوع
يختلف في التوصيل في تحسب نسبه الارجاع
ففي تكاليف مختلفه اللي موجوده هناك فهذا
يؤثر على الاسعار اكيد اكيد ما في شك هذا
عليه موظفين وعليه مختلف بس بالاخير
المنتج يعني متوفره بالشكل المناسب يعني
ما يصير يكون الفرق مره كبير
التكاليف المجمل
وعلى فكره حتى الاون لاين له تكاليف برضو
عاليه يعني تكاليف برضو تختلف عنه
تاثيرها على التسعير بين القناتين ما هو
يعني ما هو بالحجم العالي
بالمجمل بالعاده نفس السعر ممكن بين وقت
واخر يكون عليه عروض تختلف بس
ولا اذا صار يعني الفرق مره كبير يعني ما
حد بيشتري يعني ممكن يصير مرحله انه يروح
المحل وبعدين خلاص يقول تدري خليه وبشتريه
وش يختلف عليكم اختلاف برضو اضطرينا
نستثمر بشكل اكبر يعني
كان فريق المندوبين اللي عندنا طرينا
نستثمر بشكل اكبر
صراحه نشتغل مع الكل
بس اضطرينا يعني حجم الفريق التوصيل
السواقين اللي يوصلون زاد عندنا
لكننا نشتغل يعني بشكل اكثر من 80% من
الشركات الشحن بس مع الوقت يعني زاد
المناديب وزاد السواقين لان انت ما تقدر
يعني
ما تقدر تخاطر انك يعني ساعات محتاج انك
توصل من المستودع الفرع بشكل الوثير اسرع
فتخيل انك بتصير ابطا واصعب انها تتعامل
مع شركات شحن تاخذ منك بتوديها للمستودع
مركزي وبعدين اليوم اللي بعده تطلع لا
اصرع لك انك انت يكون عندك الفريق اللي
على الاقل تعرف انه يعني كحد ادنى قادر
انه يغطي واذا زاد عنده مثلا ساعه اعلى
يقدر ياخذ طلبات الاون لاين ويوصلها
للمنتجات وفي الفروع تتاكد انه يوصلها لحد
الادنى على الاقل يعني ضروري انه يكون
عندك القدره يعني انك
وهي للامانه عمليه شوي معقده بس فريق
العمليات يعني
اتقنها بشكل عالي ولا يزال يستثمر فيها
بشكل عالي انا وين الطلبيات اللي استخدم
فريق اللي عندك وين اللي تستخدم فري لانسر
وين اللي تستخدم شركات الشحن وكم فرع وصلت
السعوديه الان
تقريبا قريب نوصل للخمسين ان شاء الله ما
شاء الله
والله في اكثر من 15 16 مدينه وفتره قصيره
جدا قصيره صحيح والله ما كانت يعني
بالبدايه الخطه يعني بالبدايه بدينا
كتجربه
في يعني اول فرع بديناه في شهر 12 2020
بدك تجربه صراحه وقلنا اوكي اذا ان شاء
الله كل شيء اللي بعدها نحاول بخمسه
والسنه اللي بعدها عشره
بصراحه يعني ممتن بشكل كبير الفريق ادى
دور غير طبيعي
خلال فتره سنتين
تجاوزت 50
فرعون في كل مكان
جهد جبار وغير طبيعي للامانه كان الاداء
يعني
ممتاز وحسينا ان التوقيت جدا مناسب يعني
بدينا لا تنسى مره ثانيه في وقت على لا
نزال ما انتهينا من كورونا يعني على وقت
الافتتاح كان معنا اعضاء فريق
صار في يعني يتكفلت المطارات مره ثانيه
عندنا ناس بصعوبه اطلعوا برا المملكه يعني
كانت فتره جدا جدا مؤلمه لناس كثير
كنشاط لساتك بادي يعني لو يمكن انت بادي
في ظروف طبيعيه يمكن كان من الصعب جدا انك
تلقى مكان
فيعني الناس من السوق وانه في العقارات
يعني كان يعني حسينا انه في اماكن والله
لو تحلم لا يمكن لو الاوضاع طبيعيا من
الصعب انك تلقاها بس كورونا طلعت لكم ناس
كثير
كورونا سببت لخبطه كثير ويعني نظرتنا كانت
ما هي قصيره نظرتنا نظره طويله انه لا
يمكن انه يستمر يعني للابد
فلازم يعني الامور ان شاء الله تتعافى
وترجع لوضعها الطبيعي
فكان ضغط صراحه جدا كبير على الفريق انك
يعني تقدر خلال فتره قصيره انك تنمو النمو
هذا بس الحمد لله يعني ممتن جدا يعني دعم
صراحه من جميع الاطراف حتى يعني من
المستثمرين من قائمه
فريق عمل ادى جهد جبار صراحه نقول الازمه
اللي صارت في القطاع العقاري التجاري منه
تقدر تستفيدوا منها في التوسع بشكل سريع
الحمد لله يعني كان قرار استراتيجي صراحه
في الحمد لله يعني ما ندمنا ولا يعني
ما كانت يعني عبث يعني بديناها يعني كان
عندنا خطه توسع اوكي جرب في المكان هذا
وبعدين في فئه ثانيه فئه ثالثه
ليش حسيت انكم محتاجين انكم توصلون لها
العز من فروع يعني لو برجع للكلام
موجود على الارض اتوقع ممكن يكون فرعين
ثلاثه في كل مدينه يغطي لك الاحتياجات
صحيح ممتاز الحقيقه اللي شفناه ان يعني
قطاع الاونلاين ما يعني
اقل من 5% من حجم السوق قلبي كثير من
مقارنه بيخلينا نقول سوق الالكترونيات ولا
غيره انت عارف ايش تشتري فاذا انت حابب
تكون في مجال وشايف
الفرصه اللي فيه وحاب انك تكون يعني من
المبادرين ومن الاوائل في المجال هذا
ما تقدر تصير بدون ما تكون عندك تواجد
اوف لاين
يعني اذا تبي تصير يعني بتكون من حد انك
تكون فقط
اذا انت تبغى تكون عندك ماركه ليدر وحجمك
في السوق كبير لازم انك تكون يعني موفر
منتجك وقريب من العميل يعني اعتقد ان
اليوم وصلنا تقريبا
85% يمكن من سكان المملكه في يمكن فرع اي
قريب عليهم خلال نصف ساعه وقادر انك تحصل
فيه افضل جوده وخدمه وفحص نظر
فيعمل فرق مره كبير بالنسبه لنا فانتشارك
عموما هدفه فقط مركز المبيعات ولا زي مثلا
اذكر حقين العود يقول لك احيانا نتواجد في
لوكيشنات لاغراض
للامانه كل فرع يدرس نتوسع وما نتوسع على
يعني بالنسبه لنا ضروري انك تكون يعني
ما هو الهدف تسويقي ولو انه ما في شك
يخدمك تسويقيه يعني لما يكون عندك لوحه
والناس عارفه وتمر يعني
له قيمه تس ما في شك لكن لا هو برضو مكان
تقدر تفحص فيه تقدر تلقى فيه المنتجات
اللي تناسبك
ويعني يخدم الكل يخدم كشركه وطبعا يخدم
المبيعات ما في شك وقرار
التوسع كيف كانت تستخدم قرارات من وين
تروحون له بعد الفرع الاول وبعد الثاني
بعد الثالث اي مدينه فيها جدا ممتاز
السؤال الفرع الاول كان تجربه فكان يعني
ضروري احرصنا كل الحرص يعني تاخذ جميع
العوامل والاسباب انه يعني يكون قدر
الامكان ناجح قادر انك اداره بسبب حكم
التواجد والمركز في الخبر لان نكون قريبين
عليه
واننا نفهم يعني او حتى اذا فجل ايش سبب
فشله بس قصدي
مثلا بيانات تساعدكم
يعني انت تخدم قبل لا تبدا اوفلاين خدمت
200 الف عميل فعندك خلفيه مره كويسه ولا
وين تواجد العملاء وين الاماكن لازم تكون
موجود
لا نخدم والله الكل بس بالبدايه مبدئيا
ضروري يعني قلنا المنطقه الشرقيه ما تشكل
يدوب عشرين بالميه لازم يكون نتواجد في
الرياض لازم كلنا نتواجد في جده لازم في
المدن الرئيسيه يعني بدينا اول استراتيجيه
اوكي اغطي المدن الرئيسيه بعدين نبدا في
المدن الكبيره يعني مثل مكه المدينه المدن
الثانويه وبعدين بدينا حتى يعني
اخر الافتتاحات وصلنا يعني ابو عريش
وجازان فيعني
وجدا سعيدين انه وصلنا للدرجه هذه حتى
ممكن تصل الى مدن بكثافه 200,000 او اقل
وتلقى رواج وتلقى طلب للمنتج وتلقى تعاطي
ايجابي للعملاء
لا الحمد لله يعني الى الان لا
والتوزيع انتم متكفلين فيه بالكامل
ومتعاقدين مع الشركات بين المدن
الاماكن البعيد يعني المدن الرئيسيه احنا
عندنا ثلاث مستودعات رئيسيه في الرياض وفي
جده وفي الخبر
[موسيقى]
المدن الثانويه القريبه من المدن الرئيسيه
احنا نغطيها الاماكن اللي تكون بعيده مثلا
تبوك او اذا نزلت الجنوب لا الى الان يعني
نتعامل مع شركات شحن وتواجدكم على الارض
كيف غير في التعامل مع المنافسين او نظره
المنافسين لكم
والله سؤال كويس يمكن افضل تساله اللي في
القطاع بس نظرتنا حقيقه يعني
نرى ان عملنا قاعد يكبر
السوق لانه ما نرى اننا صراحه اخذنا حصه
سوقيه من منافسين على قد ما احنا من
الاساس يعني اذا دخلت او رحت الموقع
غالبيه المنتجات من الاساس ما هي موجوده
يعني كانك تقول المنتج ما كان موجود
فصحيح وفرته بطريقه افضل يمكن يعني ما
ننفي يمكن يكون فيه اثر بس من اطلاعنا على
السوق وسؤالنا مع ناس كثير ما يعني يعني
اللي ادائها كويس لان تشغيله وادارته
كويسه واللي اداء سيء يعني تغير ظروف في
السوق او غيره يعني بما انتم جايين
وفي محلات احنا مو ارخص
في في الارخص بس بجوده مختلفه يعني عملنا
يعني اقدر اقول لك
اذا اخذنا جانب سوق اخر خذ مثلا قطاع
الملابس
تقدر تقول اللي قاعدين نسويه زي ما اتش ان
ام ولا ساره يعني ما بيضرب امثله واشياء
كثير يعني هم شغالين
سعره في متناول الجميع جودته كويسه
يعني ما اعتقد وجودهم اخذ حصه سوقيه من
الناس ثانيين بس من الاساس السوق كان يعني
متعطش ما فيه المنتجات الكافيه فهو بالشكل
هذا خليني اخذ قطاع اخر
مزارع وغيرهم براندات معروفه ويتنافسون
يعني ما راح تقول والله ما راح اشتري من
البراند الغالي لاني اقدر اوفر مع زارا
ولا اوفر الا في هذا
فئه سعريه يعني نصور وقد اكون مخطئ النقطه
هذه اتصور انه في قطاع البصريات في
النظارات تحديدا
ما في وعي كافي في الاختلاف بين البراندات
يناسبون النظاره الشمسيه حلوه ويعرفون
يمكن الاسم اسمين بس ما في ارتباط كبير في
براند الطبي ما فيه ارتباط عالي الشمس شوي
اكثر بس نرجع مره ثانيه من الاساس بسبب
انه عندك برانزا عالميه لو تشوف كم حجم
الاستثمار التسويق اللي يعملونا يكاد لا
يوجد
والله في فرصه كبيره انك ممكن انك تبني
براند محلي يوفر المنتج هذا ويحاكي السوق
والفئه المستهدفه بشكل
الطبيه اقل الشمسيه الى حد ما لا طبعا في
يعني في يعني نقدر نشوف الداتا على فكره
بشكل واضح يعني نقدر نشوف من خلال الموقع
عندنا كم عدد الناس اللي تبحث عن برانز
معينه بس على العميل الواحد بس ما هي قد
مثلا نظرات الطبيه يعني اقل ارتباط
اقل ارتباط هو في هل زي الملابس وبعدين
العدسات اللاصقه العدسات اللاصقه يعني في
ارتباط اكثر لانه منتج وعارفه ومتعود عليه
النظارات الشمسيه مثلا في عملاء
واحد ولا من براندين ولا عنده ولا عالي في
الحقيقه في كذا وفي كذا يعني بدون ذكر
اسماء اكيد في اشياء يعني معروفه
صحيح مالها تسويق محلي بس تلقاها في
هوليود تلقاها رؤساء دول يلبسونها اكيد
هذه في ناس تبغاها انا ليش اسالك
يعني صعب اننا نكون قادرين اننا
متميزين ومنافسين فيها بشكل جيد فاذا ما
في ارتباط كبير في البراندات في النظارات
الشمسيه ليش دخلك في السالفه هل معناتها
انكم اجبرت المنافسين مثلا انهم ينزلون
اسعارهم بحكم
اني بعيد شوي التشبيه
قطاع مختلف ولا نزال يعني حجمنا ما هو
يعني
باللي يؤثر على كثير لاعبين مثلا في
البصريات اتكلم عن نفسي
هذا قد يكون التاثير انه خلاص طالب
المحل الارخص
يعني ممكن مثلا مشهور عنده رغبه هديه ولا
يمكن في السنه ولا في السنتين ممكن تشتري
شيء عالي لكن لا يتعارض من انك تدخل ايوه
وتشتري نظاره ب200 300 تكون عندك في
السياره تكون عندك في المكتب تكون عندك في
البيت وتتغير زي ما انت ملابسك ممكن تشتري
من لكن ممكن تشتري اشياء غاليه العارض ولا
يعني انك سويت الشيء هذا انك ما تقدر يعني
احنا شريحه العملاء اللي نستهدفها يعني
ممكن تكون دخل عالي جدا
وتكون تجربه تسوق ممتعه لك وممكن تكون
يعني
دخل محدود
وتوفر منتج بشكل جيد نشوف قبل ما ندخل على
العملاء فيما يظلم منافسين غير المباشرين
مثلا منصات صحيح
[موسيقى]
اوفر لك اياه منصه واحده فهذا كيف تقدر
تتنافس معه هل تعتقد انك تقدر تقدم قيمه
كافيه ان الواحد يطلع منه ويجي عندك مره
صعب سؤال كويس صراحه يعني نحاول يعني نفهم
اكثر بس لكنها تجربه جدا مختلفه وحتى هم
لان ما عنده تخصص في مجال يعني حتى لو انت
رحت
وممكن تلقى شيء بسعر اقل بس تلقاها منتج
اخر منتج بضاعه تصريف اخر الموسم
اخذوها من موزع ولا كذا ما هي يعني لهم
يعني ممكن انها شيء يخلص وكذا يعني صعب
انك تبني عليه بزنس
ومختلف يعني ما هو ما هو نفس الشيء طبعا
احنا بالنسبه لنا
يعني انا ما اخفيك تحدي كبير لان انت لما
تكون عندك انا منصه فقط بصريات اكيد ان
عدد الزوار اللي عندك يعني اقل بكثير من
اللي عنده كميه منتجات متعدده يعني جايينك
الغرض معين يعني عارف انا بدخل المكان هذا
تحديدا انه ابن نظاره انتم اللي عقرتهم
بس كنت اسالك على مين هم اغلب العملة
عندكم فعليا او اذا ما تبغى تتكلم عن ايوه
اجمالا مين هم الاغلب اللي يقبلون على
اللي خلينا نقول اللي يشكلون بالنسبه
لاكبر المبيعات هل هم مثلا
الاناث ذكور ولا ما في اي ترند في كويس
السؤال صراحه مع الوقت قاعد يتغير يعني
اقدر اقول لك اذا احنا بالبدايه بدينا
وتركيز اكثر عدسات بشكل طبيعي انه
يستخدمون العدسات الاناث اكثر من الرجال
الالوان طبعا ميه بالم الالوان يعني والله
ما تدري يمكن في رجال بس قليل يعني
غالبيتهم غالبيه غلبيتهم نساء
العدسات الشفافه في الرجال والمساء بس
برضه اكثر يعني اقدر اقول لك نسائي اكثر
يعني يمهم المظهر مناسبه معينه رجال يمكن
اذا راح جنب ولا بيلعب كوره ولا رياضه
ممكن اكثر يلبس عدسات
فطبيعي مع الوقت كانت نسبه اكثر نساء مع
الوقت
يعني كنا يمكن 80% اليوم يمكننا 60 40%
ايناس بس اكثر شيء
صحيح بس يعني
تقريبا هل تعتقد هذا الشيء يعود لانهم
يبون مثل يحبوني يغيرون كثير
الموضوع مرتبط في وعي مثلا رجال ما يحبون
يشتروا النظارات الشمسيه لا
لا يعني انت تقدر تقول والله بيضه ولا
دجاجه انت بادي بوشه اذا انت استهدفت من
الاساس كحمله تسويقيه وتستهدف نساء اكثر
طبيعي انك اللي بيجيك الزبائن بس اذا حطيت
ميزانيه وتستهدف رجالك اكثر طبيعي بيجيك
رجال وبرضو على المنتجات اللي عندك فمره
ثانيه الشركه شيء ولما كنت كمنصه اول سنه
90% قاعد تبيع عدسات يختلف اليوم اذا انت
والله لا نظارات النظارات الطبيه الكل
يحتاجها بغض النظر انت يعني عندك
برا السعوديه
يعني كفروع
يعني نفس اللي صاير في السعوديه نفس
قاعدين نمر فيه في جميع دول الخليج يعني
ما هو ما هو مختلف
سابق اي اي يعني تركيزنا كله على يعني
اذا انا اخذت مثلا حجم السوق
المملكه 50% تقريبا من ناتج محلي للدول
الخليج فاذا انت تبغى تكون لك وجود لك نمو
كذا طبيعي انك تكون يعني في
يعني باقي دول الخليج طبعا حط في بالك نفس
الاشكاليه اللي تمر فيها السعوديه
من ناحيه فجوه السوق نفس الشيء موجود في
الامارات في الكويت في البحرين
في سلطنه عمان وباقي الدول
[موسيقى]
كله يعني
كاونلاين الان كمحلات متاجر في اربع دول
حاليا ان شاء الله يعني قبل نهايه السنه
نغطي الباقي بس كلهم مره ثانيه السعر اللي
في مثاله للجميع
ما هي الفئه اللي لها اكثر حصه سوقيه
واحنا
رهاننا وتوقعهم مع الوقت لا اكبر حصه
سوقيه الناس اللي شغالين في الفئه السعر
العاليه واللي زي ما قلت لك بالبدايه خليه
الدول
دائما اللي بالسعر اللي بالمتناول الجميع
هو اللي يكون اعلى حصه سوقيه انت فقط عندك
في الخليج اللي صاير المنتجات اللي مره
غاليه هي اللي
الناس يقبلون عليها سؤال صراحه مره كويس
هي مشكله تعرض وطلب يعني هذا السبب اللي
خلانا خلانا نحس انه والله في شحف العرض
والعرض هو اللي يعني
اقدر اقول لك مثلا خذ قطاع مختلف تماما
قبل دانكن دونات يعني ايش حصه السوقيه
للدوله ما تقدر تقول بيت الدونات بس يعني
في طلب بس ما كان في حد قاعد يوفر العرض
هذا فانت حاليا بنفس الوضع يعني صاير عندك
الفئه العاليه واللي بسعر عالي مخدوم
الفئه اللي خلينا نقول رخيصه وجوده يمكن
متدنيه موجوده بس اللي بالنص ما موجود بس
لو بتشوفوا سوق واحد
فهمت النقطه هذه بالنسبه لي عشان كذا
السؤال الثاني انه لو بتشوفوا كلكم في سوق
واحد فكم بتكون
يعني تمثل من الحجم السوق هذا كله بس
علشان اتاكد اني فهمتك بشكل كويس احنا
الفئه اللي نستهدفها جميع المستهلكين لاي
شريحه البصريات اذا انت شخص انا فهمته منك
اذا انت شخص تبحث عن المنتج اللي بسعر مره
عالي وبراند
عالي جدا
ايوه مو المكان
اغلب العملاء أنا منك اغلب السوق اغلب
اللي موجود يعني اقدر اقول لك لاعبين في
السوق الموجودين يوفرون الشيء هذا هم اكثر
ناس طبعا في اشياء موجوده بالصراحه ما هي
يعني ما تكون اصليه
في المناطق يعني
لانهم في اماكن يمكن في مولات مميزه يمكن
في الوجه في كل مكان عندهم تغطيه ممتازه
في الفئه الثانيه اللي بسعر اقل وبرضو
مخدومه بس برضو جودتها متدنيه فاحنا مره
ثانيه
ايوه لحالكم سعر جدا مناسب بجوده عاليه
ارخص يعني بدا الناس تدخل في السوق لكن لا
يزال في نظرنا يعني رهاننا انه يعني ما
شاء الله يعني الشعب غالبيته 70% اقل من
عمره 30 ضعف النظر زي تساقط الشعر يعني
اكثر
فيعني مع الوقت حيكون في طلب اكثر واكثر
من منتجات البصريه
هذه تقلل الناس اللي
موقف حلم موقف ما اشوف انه يعني
[موسيقى]
زي يعني زي السمنه واللي يسوي تكميم مثلا
او اللي لابس نظارات ممكن واحد لابس
نظارات يسوي عمليه الليزر عادي ولا هي ما
تحلك المشكله يعني ممكن بعد خمسه عشر سنين
تضطر انك تستخدم منتجات تصوير والله يعني
نتمنى يعني يكون في حل بس حتى يعني لا
تزعل ممكن تلبس نظارات شمسيه الشمس ما راح
الشمس
من اكثر الاسواق في العالم اللي ما شاء
الله الشمس حتى في الشتاء يعني فالطلب
فيها عالي حلو وين بتروحون تستمرون على
موضوع التوسع في الفروع ولا في خطط
مستقبليه ممكن والله صراحه لا نزل نشوف ان
الفرصه كبيره
[موسيقى]
اهدفنا اننا نستمر في التوسع بشكل كبير لا
نزال نرى ان يعني انا لو شفت مثلا حجم
القطاع
لو بس في السعوديه عندك اكثر من 2000 محل
البصريات
يعني نرى انه بالعكس في مجال مره كبير انك
تستمر تتوسع بشكل مره كبير في المملكه
وباقي الخليج طبعا في برضو يعني ما اخفيك
قاعدين ندرس نماذج عمل اخرى اشياء ثانيه
ممكن نبنيها
فكرنا في مصنع فكرنا انك تدخل التوزيع
غيره
امتياز تروح سوق خارج بس يعني بعضها كلها
افكار فطور دراسه ليش ما دخلت بالسوق اللي
احنا فيه لا يزال جدا كبير ومره ثانيه
قاعدين نبني فريق يعني حجم الفرصه اللي
قدامك مره كبيره ممكن انك تكون متشتت اذا
يعني ما تقدر يعني تسوي كل شيء ليش
اول شيء احنا مالنا سنتين لسه وصلنا 50
اللي تقول لي اليوم هل احنا مثلا جاهزين
يعني ممكن بعد كم شهر لكن جاء طلبات بس
انت كابزنس لساتك توك بادي تدير نفسك ما
انت في درجه استعداد انك تقدر تقول والله
يعني انا في جاهزيه من ناحيه نوحي كثيره
تشغيليه
انك تقدر تشرف على لانك اذا بتسوي شيء
تبغى تسويه وانت وصلت الى مرحله من النضج
النكاد انك تسويه بمستوى جيد حلو ولا كم
موظف وصلت الان
مجمل ايوه تقريبا 650 يعني ان شاء الله
على نهايه السنه اتوقع المفروض اننا نعدي
يمكن 780 السعوديه كم السعوديه 420 والحمد
لله نفخر انه يعني اكثر من 75% سعوديين ما
شاء الله
مره ماشي
تجاوزت 50 مليون ايرادات اخر سنه
عشرين بس عشان نعرف حجم العمل كم تقريبا
الايرادات اكثر من اقل من عطني بس رقم
فضفاض عام مبهم عشان يبين يعني انت ممكن
تستمر مع يعني
يعني على نهايه كمجمل من بدينا لين 2022
تجاوزنا 200 مليون ما شاء الله بس في 22
الحاله هل تجاوزته مثلا 100 مليون اي طبعا
حلو عشان
[موسيقى]
في نفس الخبره ونفس المعلومات اللي عندك
وش القرارات اللي بتاخذها
والله سؤال صراحه مره ممتاز ما رتبتها
يعني لكن الحمد لله الحمد لله اعتقد اننا
يعني اول شيء توفيق رب العالمين
[موسيقى]
تفادينا اخطاء مره كثير يعني اقدر اقول لك
90% من اللي سويناه يعني خدمنا برضو
التوقيت لو رجعت لاول يوم وانت معك نفس
الخبره الحين ونفس المعلومات اكيد
لا بس يعني مره ثانيه اللي تعرف اليوم
يعني في اشياء مره صعب تعرفها لولا انك
بديتها وحتى لو بدينا من الاساس احنا مو
جاهزين احنا يا دوب يعني اول سنه سنتين زي
ما قلت لك لسه ما عندنا المنتجات خلفيه
منتجاتنا عدسات فما انت اصلا جاهز ولو
بديت ما راح تبدا بالطريقه اللي زي ما هي
اليوم
كل شيء يعني محتاج محتاج وقت من ناحيه
يعني يعني ممكن خلنا نقول انت طبعا وضعك
كبزنس مختلف يعني دخلت في كذا جوله
استثماريه اكيد ان في يعني في قرارات
استراتيجيه معينه في استثمار معين اكيد
انه معرفتك ايش المنتج اللي اكثر عليه
رواج انت عرفته ايش الحملات التسويقيه
الفاشله وايش الناجحه ايش الاستثمار
التقني المناسب انك تكون مستثمر اكثر من
حاجه او اقل من الحاجه فاكيد يعني لو يرجع
الوقت اقدر اقول لك ما راح تحتاج نفس درجه
بتتفادى اشياء كثير بس كخط تسلسل زمني
لا الحمد لله يعني توفقنا خاصه مع كورونا
يعني صراحه
يعني
الحمد لله بفضل رب العالمين انه
حقيقه من القطاعات الوحيده
اقدر اقول لك اللي في فتره كورونا استفادت
والتبعاتها بعد كورونا حتى بعد ما دخلت في
قطاع التجزئه استفدت بسبب يعني على قد ما
هو كان مؤلم ومتعب لو انا مطور عقاري او
لو انا في قطاع التجزئه بس برضو توفرت فرص
لا يمكن نحلم فيها لو احنا والله في وضع
سليم كويس الحمد لله الله يعطيك العافيه
عبد الله
سؤال كويس حسيت ان المحاور كويس الله
يعافيك شكرا لكل الفريق ويعطيكم العافيه
موفقين ان شاء الله شكرا لك قبل ما تقفلوا
الحلقه اتمنى اذا عجبتك تشاركها مع اللي
حولك وتقيمها بتقييم ايجابي سواء في
اليوتيوب او في ايتونز واذا كان عندكم
ملاحظات عنها ياريتك تشاركني اياها سواء
على ايميل البرنامج سوالف ات 8.com او حتى
على حسابي في تويتر ات دبيان شكرا
لمتابعتكم وشكرا لعبد الملك ال سعيد في
اعداد الحلقه ياسر الغانم في اداره
التصوير في الاضاءه غالب محمد ومساعده
ياسر في الاخراج الابداعي وهاب موسى في
الاخراج الفني مجد القرشي في الهندسه
الصوتيه عبد العزيز المزي في التحرير
برامج بيبان في التجهيز عبد المجيد عمر
عبد الله بن الفقيه محمد عبد العزيز او في
الانتاج التنفيذي رزان دهيثم هذا سوالف
بزنس احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع